that far away this award I you know
every I was I was looking over the list
of writers who have won this award and
it really is sidess with names and
writers who I really am a major focus of
my work and to be listed amongst omegas
how's the prize value by the way is
filmed Japan has resonated to monster
how am I surprised by how regulated body
yeah I knew I really i had no idea how
how much soon we would connect with
people i mean because it's so personal
to me and the guys there was a phonetic
effectually who nativist that we really
have no idea how audiences rear axle and
the most validating part of making this
movie has been how how has they would
touch people and connecting with people
and especially to speak with a bit
affected by cancer who can really relate
to it and that depth in with that the
moon's
any story has river beauty there's one
story particular kind of guy and that's
like us for secondary to a benefit that
was green 5050 I can't prevent it and a
guy came up to me afterwards and she
said my stepfather died of cancer lung
cancer 20 years ago and my mother has
not been able to talk about about my bed
at once and after seeing the movie she's
able to talk about it for the first time
and that really like that really has
such as one that's bad the movie can
have that kind of um I think it's really
leading the screw the word is really
special I think that these are a lot of
movies that are being honor to a movie
that um you know I think anything that
kind of film to me is about telling you
doing great stories to read you know
about real people and great characters
and great acting and I think there's not
a lot of room for these kinds of movies
under the you know seems like there's
less and less room for companies and I
think it's really awesome that there's
there is an event with you some harm and
these are the goals that I do only to
make and that I now acquired you know
that I want to continue making and do
it's nice to know that there
community of like-minded people I'm
right currently writing a movie it's
inspired by a vacation I took with my
grandmother when I was 14 does she and I
we went to Jamaica and ended up somehow
ended up in a couple of resorts I know
that she's also the early stages of
Alzheimer's and I lost her and if it's
gonna come on e I mean it's the same
5050 it's dramatic and comedic is all
you know hun be honest you know one of
my favorite movies is Alex of live here
anymore and I think totally it's very
much matches
because it works perfectly
I don't know it's just I think its new
just about being you know who your
characters and making sure that no joke
is at their expense and that you know
any anything that they say whether it's
funny or dramatic it just feels like
something I'm saying I think that that's
good where I stated good room out of
chocolate does it have a title know how
many rewrites will have a China before
comes out of it okay hi I'm Mary rights
did you do from the first to the final
four Vicki convicted oh man I know you
know they're the structure in the movie
stayed almost the same but with you know
I know it's just I rewrote it probably
you know over legal drought I really you
know dozens of little rewrites and then
probably you know five or six you know
big you know read right over over the
course of three years taking taking the
film from a screenplay and then finally
seeing and visualizing the film but
there's anything that surprised you that
may be expanded out in your vision from
the screenplay when we came
you know I have to see it off you know
right I'm really moving having been on a
yacht as I said every day and so you
know in spite of that when I watched the
first cut I really am I had this weird
reaction where I the movie they look so
real characters felt so genuine and the
performances were so incredible that I
really like who recognized the words
that I wrote because it felt so true to
the character than that that was really
I was not high have originally so I
didn't go to the section that sounds
really strange but cool it sort of like
there's a movie yeah the movies with in
my head for so long it was really nice
that it was sort of you know it was
staged for something else
congratulations